Colin I get the real quick uh is the  Penguin series gonna happen the penguin  uh shooting here in New York I think if  it goes ahead  um I read the first episode  which was just so tasty and so so  unusual it's so unusual as the character  was on the page and what Matt Reeves  kind of envisioned when he was when he  was thinking of this iteration of the  penguin of ours so yeah it'll be I think  six or eight hours I'm supposed to read  episode two and three within the next  week and just a really good company of  people and Matt Reeves is all over it  and it sure matters you know borderline  OCD when it comes to his focus and and  trying to do something new and and  original and and with feeling and  aesthetic and all that good stuff so it  would be I would love I had such a blast  doing that Steve it was so amazing it  was just so much fun you know it's just  unbridled I had so much permission to  just do whatever